welcome back everyone to episode number
15 of the beginner to master speedrun uh
I know the last one was just a single
game in episode 14 I'll try and make up
for that today with more games and
coming into today my rating is
981 uh so I am hoping to break 1,000 ELO
I've switched my profile picture to a
photo of myself I don't know what year
this was maybe 2003
2004 so some tournament I I won a medal
so hopefully I can win uh at least the
prize of breaking 1,000 ELO today now
let's hop into it I'll join the 10minute
pool playing boric bik and I'll play
E4 and I'm sticking with the same
opening
repertoire that I've been playing thus
far the series it's also the same
opening repertoire I used to play when I
was is younger very classic
Italian uh usually black will choose
between Knight F6 or Bishop C5 here
those are the two main
moves D6 it's a little bit passive uh
because the blocks in the bishop but
it's playable uh this is what we can
call uh props a delayed filor fidor is
uh D6 on move
two so I'll just continue developing
Knight
C3 hope there's sound
she didn't troubleshoot the the move
sounds but yeah hopefully it's working
we see Bishop G4 I'm going to play H3
here now there is a possible trap that
black could fall into from this
position uh Bishop H5 is like the most
natural move to maintain the
pin but as far as I know Bishop H5 is a
tactical
mistake and it would be nice if uh we
see this
move yeah yeah now it's been a while
since I've looked at this line so I want
to make sure that the tactics are
working I'm pretty sure they
are I'm going to take the
pawn and say oh no my
queen someone call an
ambulance but probably not for
me uh this is the classic legal's
Checkmate if black takes the
queen then White's mating in two with
Bishop
F7 and yeah we're going to see this play
out so King E7 and Knight to D5 will be
Checkmate I will have some explaining to
do uh cuz there were some other lines
that would not lose immediately for
black um but that's a a nice start to
the episode episode A lot of people are
challenging me um but we'll hold off for
now so yeah this is a classic one and
this might be like the most common way
to get the legal's Checkmate but there's
a lot of different openings that kind of
feature the same
pattern
so I first want to note that the reason
why I play H3 and not immediately Knight
takes
E5 is here okay of course if black takes
a queen it's the same Maiden two uh but
black could take on E5 with a knight and
this is just bad for white because I'm
just losing a piece my Queen's still
attacked and bishop's defended my
Bishop's attacked and White's not
getting
anything so H3 was crucial to provoke
the bishop to
H5 and then after takes you might be
wondering what if the Knight just takes
here hitting the bishop on C4
and it still works for white because
after takes I can take the bishop and
after Knight takes C4 white is
temporarily down a piece but there is a
move here for white to regain the piece
uh and if you want to try and find it
feel free to pause the video but the
move is Queen to
B5 and this is a nice nice use of the
geometry of the board uh double
attacking the Knight and the king and
after the
this white is happily up a pawn um so it
did take a lot of work to to win the
center Pawn but it's a very nice
tactical sequence and I imagine there's
been probably thousands of games that
featured this line probably across Le
and chess.com
so um yeah I hope I explained everything
there uh if you have any more questions
about this line feel free to leave them
below I will note that
uh probably taking is a better move or
retreating um but if takes I'd be happy
to take and then threat mates and yeah
life is still good here for
whites so um let's move on new
game playing Ismail leren ra
952 if I win this game I'll gain eight
rating points so inching my way closer
I'll play Knight
C6
and we'll have a a more standard
Italian in this case okay I was going to
say that I don't play D6 cuz I want my
Bishop more active White's going for a
friy liver but this just hangs a knight
um I'm wondering if white maybe will try
this move which does look scary because
it hits the queen and hits a bishop but
I'm going to take the pawn on G2
counterattacking The Rook white doesn't
have time to take the bishop
and meanwhile yeah the rook and the pawn
are now
attacked and this is just an opening
disaster for white so I won that game
even quicker than the first one this is
feeling like a a real speedrun now two
games in uh still less than 10 minutes
of recording let's just go again rated
[Music]
this might be the final game my rating
is in the the three
digits I'm craving a fourth
digit so we have the same opening same
Italian okay so here I'm not going to
play Knight
G5 uh as we learned from the previous
game um I'll just play D3 it's one of
the most classical
moves getting ready ready to activate
the
bishop here I'll start with Knight to
C3 we have a Four
Knights this does have um kind of a
symmetrical nature but with black
castling King
side uh I don't have to Castle so soon
and I'm going to start with Bishop
G5 I'm pretty sure I've had similar
openings in previous games of the
speedrun the idea is to very simply play
night D5 and attack the pinned Knight
I'm pretty sure this is a mistake like
even though it's one of the most
standard moves for black in this
opening uh the problem now is the
knight's attack twice and the bishop
can't Retreat to break the pin I'm
pretty much guaranteed to take at some
point and ruin the Palm structure for
black on the king side so my opponent
like did follow basic principles like
castled early to developed does have
peace Harmony but uh yeah against this
plan from White Black's position is is
already not so great it's possible I've
had the same position I remember one
game several episodes ago that featured
something very
similar okay Bach is going for the same
idea of maybe going for Knight D4 uh
there's a few differences though first
of all I could play C3 preventing Knight
d
for also I've not committed to castling
so I probably don't want to Castle King
side so
[Music]
soon of course I could start with taking
either
way like one idea is to take with a
knight Pawn takes and then Bishop
H6 which looks
appealing I could play H3 kick the
bishop back and then maybe go for
G4 yeah there's definitely some forcing
options to consider I could also start
with
C3 and then kind of just put the ball
back in back
court I'm going to slow play I'm going
to play
C3 um I mean it's possible that H3 or
Knight takes F6 where were better moves
but um I think this is just a very
useful move in preventing the knight
from activating also in some cases I
want to play Pawn B4 and
expand I don't really see how black can
kind of get out of the
Quagmire that they're in cuz a move like
H6 will lose a pawn after H6 and this
Pawn is overworked I can take take and
then
take Knight E7 does break the
pin but
it it leaves the Knight less
defended um and now it's a question do I
want to take with the Knight or with the
Bishop
first both moves are very
attractive I mean if I take with the
bishop then if Pawn takes Knight takes
I'm winning the bishop on
G4 but if I take with Knight first takes
takes I maintain the pin and then I have
the plan of checkmating just by bringing
the queen
in
yeah I'm going to go for the mating idea
I'm going to take here
first I mean both moves I think were
pretty crushing for
white
but I think this will lead to a quicker
win the king is completely stuck Bishop
Bishop is so strong on
F6 and I mean I'm already threatening
Queen D2 and getting the queen
in so my opponent like honestly didn't
make too many glaring mistakes in this
game especially for this rating level
like there wasn't an obvious blunder it
was more
just um not being aware of the danger
from early on walking into this uh this
very powerful
plan after this game I'll share what
black could have done
better and this position is already
pretty close to force
mate like the threat is is not Queen G5
cuz Knight G6 but the threat is actually
Queen
H6 and then Queen G7 will be pretty much
Unstoppable very typical mating
pattern I guess there's one move to
delay the mate one spite check and this
game brings back a lot of nostalgia for
me cuz like the first couple years I was
playing chess this is like one of the
main strategies I went for in a lot of
games like Bishop G5 and Knight
D5 it took me several years to actually
learn what black should do to not get
into so much trouble from early
on so my opponent is taking time here
can't blame them like sometimes when the
position is hopeless you still want to
take your time and see if there's any
last resources but
yeah there's there's no running there's
no
hiding okay so we do see the Spight
check but now there's no more spy
checks and like if I want to I could pre
moove Queen
G7 actually I might as
well just so I don't Mouse
slip okay um nice game that was the
longest game so far this episode I broke
1,000 and yeah I
mean I I think D6 was a like the first
kind of big
mistake even though the engine says this
is
playable if we go
back like I think in this
position black needs to be very
careful maybe one of the best moves is
Bishop E7 like even though the bishop is
a bit more passive here it does prevent
White's idea of Knight
D5 and uh yeah completely diffuses a
pin another approach sometimes what
players will do is just
H6 preventing Bishop G5 entirely and
then then black can continue with T6 and
castle and not have to worry about the
same
ideas um but yeah hopefully some lessons
to take away from my opponent if we go
forward with what happened in the game
yeah after C3 I mean black was still
alive here like the engine engine says
White's only slightly better uh Bishop
E6 would have been the best move to
challenge the Knight get ready to take
the Knight on D5 and then here I mean I
probably would have taken and then takes
and then Bishop H6 but black is still
alive here like it's it's hard to
generate ideas immediately and uh the
game would go on from
here so uh I've officially broken
1,000 um do I keep it going I ride the
momentum let's keep it going let's play
a few more at least one
more I do want to deliver a longer
episode especially for the
holidays there were a lot of comments
the previous episode of people kind of
upset that I only he featured one game
so uh okay let's let's start with Knight
C6 the Stafford Gambit was in my muscle
memory but we'll have a
scotch it's the beginning of the scotch
opening oh this idea isn't this like a
famous like Tik Tock trap where a lot of
players play
H6 and then Knight takes
F7 and then King takes and then Queen
wait a minute Queen
H5 I definitely saw this on
like I think it was Tik Tok like there's
some trend of like all these channels
sharing this weird
trap I can't remember if H6 is a good
move or just
losing but I don't think I want to play
H6 because of like these these ideas of
Bishop C4 and queen
H5
so yeah I remember like studying this in
depth a few months
ago and just laughing at how ridiculous
this this opening
is but I think I think I'll just play a
normal developing move like this should
be
fine and then if Bishop C4 I can play
Knight E5 attacking and
defending I'm definitely going to have
to like research this opening
afterwards I will say Knight G5 it
violates a lot of principles in the
opening like moving the same piece twice
away from the center but um
I'm pretty sure it had a venomous trap
if if black is not
careful but it is somewhat of um a hope
chest Type move like White's hoping that
I I go wrong and assuming I don't go
wrong I'm uh I'm up a pawn here I'm not
concerned about
F7 being a Target cuz Okay if takes I
take with Knight and White's not going
to have enough
there wow white counterattacks my knight
so both Knights are attacked
here but what I can do is take the
bishop
first and then once the queen takes back
then I'll take the
Knight looks like I'm winning a
piece so white takes on F7 yeah this is
um somewhat of an in between
move my king will be a little bit more
exposed
and this this is a triple attack White's
hitting my king and both of these pawns
Queen and Bishop Target
[Music]
C7 I think D5 is a move to go
for cuz that way I'm just going for some
Central liquidation I'm also opening up
my
Bishop I don't mind if Queen takes C7
like we would trade queens and then I
win the pawn on e4
Queen takes D4 is possible and then I
can't
take because of the
pin even though there's a line where I
win back
[Music]
material okay but we see a pawn digs
D5 and now if I take with Queen White
could take this Pawn with
Chuck but then Bishop D7
[Music]
I think a an important thing to note
here
is black is is doing a very nice job of
controlling the
center like I have a bit more
development even though my king is a bit
precarious uh there's just such nice
control over like most squares in the
position and now I have a choice maybe
just Rook to C
8 which almost traps a
queen think the only safe square is
Queen
E5 I'm up a piece so I might as well go
for a queen
trade and perhaps at some point I can
win the pawn on C2 I'm trying to
calculate here if Queen E5 I could take
the queen
immediately or I could take the pawn
first which might be
preferable
opponent's taking time here like
searching for other options but I'm
pretty sure this is the only move and
maybe we'll see
C4 but in in most cases I should be
winning winning a pawn and trading
Queens yeah so if I take on
C2 then
I give white the move but my Queen's
defended Queen's not going anywhere
either and if white wants to avoid the
trade there's Queen E1 but I wouldn't
mind seeing
that I guess there's also Queen B8 there
okay we see Knight D2 now this is a
blunder because after takes the bishop
is
overworked I can take the Knight now
black is up a knight and a
bishop pawns are
equal but Knight and Bishop is a nice
material
advantage and let's not slow down let's
win more
material the tactics keep
coming yeah we're seeing a downward
spiral this is very common in ch when
one side has lost a bit of material it's
common for them to just kind of lose
even
more you just have more pieces to
generate tactics
with so I'm still very curious about
this opening if if I was supposed to
play H6 I think I'm happy with what I
did like Knight F6 was a more practical
move in the
opening there's really no way to save
The Rook here or is there maybe maybe
there is Rook
T1 CU then if I take it's just a trade
of
Rooks Rook D1 Rook E2 then white can
save the rook and the
bishop he takes
first now if I take the bishop I mean
everything is winning here but I think
it's better to take the Rook first
ensuring that I'm winning
material and now I'm up a rook and a
bishop and white
resigns
okay so I mean with a lot of these games
it's it's usually a matter of of me
sharing some some lessons afterwards but
in this
game I'm going to use stockfish to to
get a lesson of my own because Knight
G5 what I remember is
H6 takes
takes and I'm pretty sure there's a line
like Bishop
C4 and then like the most natural move
is King E8 and
then White's winning with this sequence
here here here here like Bishop
F4 some
crazy crazy line where the king just
walks up and gets
mated
so I have the evelar on engine says H6
is okay for
black because after takes takes Bishop
C4 ah so the best move in this position
is King
G6 which looks kind of ridiculous to
walk the king up but the point is to
hide the King on H7
and white can
attack but there's no there's no way to
like get a mating that as white Bishop
F7 looks scary but then probably Knight
E7 or queen
F6 and if Queen
F5 it's very close to mate but there's
G6 and then Bishop G7 and black is
surviving so
yeah for anyone that Encounters this
opening like Scotch with Knight
G5 uh you could play
H6 with the understanding that you have
to play King G6 in this position okay D5
or King E7 apparently are also playable
just don't play King
E8 but uh what I play Knight F6 in the
game is also very fine and um yeah black
is is slightly better here uh then going
forward just go forward all the
way I think everything was under control
of this
game so um I think I'll end it here past
a thousand had some some interesting
openings this uh episode had the the Lal
mate had some pretty quick games this
last one was a nice
lesson so do stay tuned for the next
episode if you have questions leave them
below thank you everyone for watching if
you like the content like And subscribe
it does help the channel and I'll see
you guys soon